- You know why I love
hip hop the most?
'Cause people that are
really in it, they work.
Like I'm in Corporate America.
I'm in Silicon Valley.
Actually, that's why I fell
in love with Silicon Valley.
Those nerds, they worked
like my hip hop friends did.
- [Envy] Mhmmm.
- I'm like, "Wait a minute,
"these kids are coding
at 2 in the morning?" Right?
Like going in the
studio last night at midtown
at 12 and
watching everybody work.
Dave needs to work.
He's working.
They're working.
- [Woman] Oh, you were there
with Yung Berg and everybody?
- I was with Berg last night.
- [Cha] He was--
- Oh, he was on the
show with you, right?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Yeah.
And you know why?
- [Woman] That's funny.
- It motivates me.
Because in Corporate America
when I go sit with CMOs and CEOs
of Fortune 500 companies,
they don't work like this.
They're done at 6.
- [Cha] That's
interesting though
because you have
the type of money
that most rappers
would probably be like,
"You know what? I'mma relax."
Hip hop guys work so
hard because that's probably
their only opportunity
to make anything.
Like really, really make--
- The ones that,
by the way, Corporate America
people are like that.
Other people are like that.
This is not a
race or a genre thing.
Most people want to
get to a certain place
and they work to be
able to enjoy and relax.
And there's a small group that
works for the fucking game.
- [Envy &amp; Gary] I work
for the game.
- I want all-time legacy.
I want people
watching this in 2059.
What's up, Jeremiah?
That's my great-great-grandson.
That's what I want.
I want all time legacy.
The reason, by the way,
the reason I'm nice and giving
away all my best content
on Instagram and stuff,
it's not because
I'm Mother Teresa.
It's because I want the
leverage of being that guy.
- [Envy] But do you
think people should do...